yeah welcome to this video against
justice but from the US now play a quiet
opening here probably transposing to
english or reggie waters so radio
playing now
yet so quiet looking set up but it can
get much more interesting later night
worth eight yeah their moves another son
that you didn't really expect
I spent two moves bring the night to a
bed square maybe it's somewhat out of
the way but it's it's not not a great
square on on g6 okay so should I take on
d4 d5 maybe take now and occupy the
center
the problem is he can go for this
typical hanging pawns but it's a very
bad version of hanging ponds where I've
got both the bishops th it out and this
gives white very pleasant position
yeah mom maybe go here and in 1095
yeah the Sun it's a quite crude looking
but you need to respect it he wants to
sacrifice on f 2 83 and or III so um
what to do I can go all night f4 but
it's not not exactly what I wanted to do
hmm move like rook d3 is not really what
I am would you like to play but maybe it
is not so bad I'm threatening h3 and 95
which is quite good well whatever h3
just h3 should buy five I could take the
night so you need to retreat now what
yeah well okay this is never never good
though simply giving me to two minor
pieces for work
and my own King position is not down not
bad
yeah only III is slightly weakened but
not clear that this song is so so
important if night f form yeah just
night air for coming now
and no 95 next move
so I'm let's um okay yeah
yeah let's concentrate and really AM
refute this yeah f6f Bishop g5 check so
I really want to win now because this is
just such bad play that you need to
review it okay got them three minor
pieces for a rock now and I'm now
getting rid of one rook which should
them should help in this position help
me to coordinate the pieces
Bishop f5
Jeff
no it can take g5 next smooth
so Bishop g5 there's some rook f7 but
it's not really dangerous and can go
there should be six or go anywhere we're
actually also here so pretty solid
continuing king g3 and 95
check
check
yeah just need to make sure to mop up
all the pawns I've got many pieces to do
that and not spend too much time so yeah
young need to even 1c5 know
see 5 or h5 would both be very nice to
win
Knight f3 he maybe goes booked one
now okay this wasn't a good idea let's
keep this Bishop here that's that's
easiest probably and I have have this
nicely nicely covered h3 we should be 12
h for a smile plan or III f2 whatever
let them the same bishop is helping okay
time warning
I wanted to go to f2 so what's a bit
silly
yeah 3 3 pieces for Luke was too much um
it's still a bit tricky if you don't
have much time on the clock with with
those pawns but you should win them one
after the other and manage somehow but
what's a bit ok very impress eyes yeah
simply this this year's is probably just
bad for black yeah plus 1 something by
the computer if there's nothing directly
happening then this is just good for
white he can nick and simply retreat
here and has has a prayer playable
position which is slightly better for
white but nothing nothing spectacular
yeah thanks for watching